hold on hold on we're gonna strap you
into this
hold on
[Music]
hey i'm melissa and i'm itoki and this
is expert amateur fraud a show where we
try to figure out who the expert is and
who's the fraud today we're going to be
interviewing three
drag queens
wow okay okay this is okay this is gonna
be interesting i'm so ready do you think
you're gonna be able to tell
oh i've never even been to a drag show
and i've been wanting to okay so this is
perfect for me i have some friends that
do drag and like literally when i see
them i'm blown away they look like
different people
oh
absolutely mostly just face are we like
am i tucking am i talking
[Laughter]
[Music]
hello
what's your name
today i'm gonna try and get one of you
into quick drag in under 15 minutes oh
yeah and then we're gonna do a little
runway walk together rock paper scissors
shoot yeah i'll be first okay cool yay
this is a wig cap we're gonna just pull
all your hair back i got a big ol head
you look incredible so beautiful when
we're done
[Applause]
can i get you to throw these on i'm
jealous i'm going to throw a bold lip on
you and then we're going to make a
glitter now what did you say your um
your name is again
miss jumai shumai if you are unfamiliar
is a hot
steamy
juicy
pork dumpling
it's perfect
i love this okay okay you're brushing
the whip pushing out a nice little bang
wiggy oh bangs bangs do you think i
could pull off bangs you would look
really good bangs honestly
what did you say you would look really
in bangs is that that is that a good
thing that's a good thing i love that so
i would look
am i allowed to say that i feel like i
would do anything you told me to do oh
yeah
that's something
why is motoki more gorgeous than i am
i love this i love this as a queer asian
american you know a lot of the times i
never really felt myself seen in a lot
of media especially growing up as a kid
like my role models were always like
cartoon characters but it was always the
female ones i was always drawn to and so
i always wanted to be able to celebrate
my femininity in a certain way but
obviously that wasn't allowed to me
growing up right um once i discovered
drag you know this is basically me not
only being able to like heal that inner
child yeah from the past but also be
able to like be the superstar that i
needed to see and be growing up what is
a persona that you've always wanted to
take on that would make you feel
effortlessly powerful oh gosh that's a
hard question um
something take it on
debuting for the very first time welcome
to the stage purple ranger
my megazord is quaking i think that
anyone can do drug because drag is an
art form that isn't tied to gender it's
not tied to ethnicity it's not tied to
age drag is an art form where you can
take wigs or makeup or theatrics or
performance and
be able to
uncover who you really are
[Music]
hello jordan hello alyssa hello and you
are purple ranger purple ranger yes
it's new and i'm working on it stuff so
it's like if zoe deschanel and joe dirt
okay i'll take it today i'm going to get
you some hair okay and we're going to
learn about some contouring the way you
reshape the face to trick people into
thinking you're a woman
i think we're going to put you in a wig
cap i was feeling pretty left out yeah
join the wig yeah i can't i'm going to
wrap this up like this i actually do
wear wigs oh perfect i don't know
you don't
is this okay
you know what
oh i'm in blue yeah well i'm wearing
blue and so so will you
i have nothing but time for this i am
not okay with it hold on hold on
we're gonna strap you into this
hold on
maybe some bangs will help you right you
want me to hold it up for you how's that
is that better oh it is actually it's
not
please just do some makeup yeah we're
gonna fix it basically what you do is
you take dark and light shades of makeup
to trick the light around you to make
your face look like it's a different
shape so i start all the way up at like
the sideburn area okay and then i just
take it down like that like straight
down and then from here i do the jaw and
i kind of start just just below where i
was before and i just kind of like that
sort of thing that to make my nose look
like it's a little turned up oh yeah i
like that i don't think you needed
nearly as much as i put on okay um
you look great though really because
everybody's kind of scaryly looking at
me
it's gonna be fine
i can fix it okay it's moments like this
that i appreciate how good i look
how good you look okay
so basically you'll take this powder
this is a great this is actually really
fierce powder i use this one myself
actually put it under your cheekbones
are you ready for the reveal yeah wow
oh my gosh
i do kind of feel iconic we're gonna try
this other wig because it's a little
nicer and i uh i thought it was really
funny to put you in the blue one do i
look like elsa i can't tell if you look
younger or older do i still look scary
no i'm into the gray hair you look great
okay do you think anybody can you drag
absolutely anybody can do drag i mean
i'm doing it so if i can do it anybody
can do it
hello
are you here you're having some sort of
a uh drag queen boot camp pretty much
i think i'm here my name is evie and
voss like the waters wait did you ever
see the parent trap yeah of course you
kind of are giving
me the hell is evian she's
the one that drank evie and water the
stepmom oh
that was quite a journey there that's
what i'm going to be kind of scary in a
good way oh good yeah so what i'm going
to do today is we're going to put some
liner on we're just going to add
to the
situation
so i've got some eyeliner here oh boy
what is your eyeliner experience
just
just a little putting it on
so when you're in drag you're basically
painting for the back of the room you
want to have the person in the very back
maybe even the lobby
see you i'm gonna need you to stand up
because i'm just really tall yeah we're
the same i feel like i'm in trouble with
the principle the way that i like to do
it is make make it look like your eyes
are being lifted you don't want anything
droopy
so follow the line of your lower lid
let's do it from the bottom line and
head upward so that way it gives you a
lift to your face that's i never knew
that that's like a really i'm like
genuinely this isn't just for the camera
thank you there you go you're welcome
tips home with you well i need you to
also feel like a drag queen as well okay
there is one more uh trick that i want
to do for you if you really want to be a
drag queen you really have to get into a
drag queen's shoes i'm with it you know
i'll take a walk in their shoes this is
not the glamorous part of drag please do
not take a video of my feet thank you
very much not for free at least
yeah thank you for i'm not worthy of
this once you get the heels and the
lashes on girl you're a woman i don't
want to ruin these wow
do you where do you put your balance
you're going to need to find your center
of balance by maybe putting a little
weight in your hip
chest out
sorry what
i know heels chest out that's how i get
the boys yeah when you're walking make
sure you put one foot in front of the
other there you go like you're on a
tightrope excellent okay excellent
you're gliding uh-huh uh-huh you kind of
look like you're on the prowl though
it's a little too sexy it's like every
year yeah sexy is the word i was gonna
use two gta 5 pokemon
very grand theft auto 5. what the hell
you actually been doing this a while no
literally wait a minute
okay okay you're killing it thank you
thank you all right give me my shoes
back please they're mine now oh he's
like whoa no
you know homecoming whenever you have to
dress up for the week and it's like
today is formal day today is like black
and white day today is they didn't call
it cross-dressing day but they just said
like swap day or whatever and so the
boys would dress as girls and the girls
would dress as boys that was kind of my
awakening for drag or the first time i
experienced drag and being more feminine
and playing with gender roles really i
for one feel
incredible yeah and you look incredible
thank you and i know you're just saying
that
so that i don't like cry how do you feel
though i feel like you know you had a
big transformation today i had some uh
awakening for sure the second those
boots came on i actually blacked out i i
don't remember anything to be honest
with you um okay so we got three
folks here evian was like making me like
tremble yeah which made me think like
she's the expert slightly erotic
yeah i was like she knew exactly what
she was doing yeah she gave me a tip
about eyeliner that not even the the
most feminine woman i know would be able
to she told me about one stood out to me
as
somewhat of a fraud oh i thought jordan
was like
that's i'm in the same boat
but right i think she was giving it away
a little bit she was but also then i was
like thinking i was like maybe that's
part of her like comedic essence of just
kind of being like whatever there was
one point where she said like oh i never
wear wigs and i was like what yes
but you're wearing one right now what
did you think of miss shumai well i'm a
little that was the one that yes because
i'm doing i am the product of miss
shumai i mean look she had a very
personal story well let's change it yeah
let's do that
so far this is kind of what we think but
if we're wrong don't kill us please this
is my voice like for this outfit i want
to lock in the boats yeah
i'm going to lock in
is that good should we
[Music]
we love all of you please don't be mad
if we guessed it you know okay
you were all literally so beautiful in
the way that you did your makeup and and
the confidence was just
oozing from everybody so we were
genuinely like having the hardest time
picking who's who
um
we thought the expert was
avion
it was a lot of confidence i felt like
you had a really good persona it was
just effortless for you to be
heavy
[Music]
i should have known you can't really
walk in those
i believe we concluded the amateur is
mishumai
that is what we decided
yes that is
only time will tell
[Music]
we felt that jordan was
the fraud
and i'm sorry
[Music]
can the
expert please raise her hand
okay okay okay
all drag is valid all bodies are valid
like you don't have to pad and have like
boobs in order to be a drag queen as a
non-binary person myself it's helped me
really embrace and be able to celebrate
and feel so much more confident in my
natural femininity
sorry
when i first joined ellie's drag scene i
started to feel like i wasn't really
good enough to be around all the other
girls and to perform and to earn the
respect but the reality is i just found
what i was good at and i really love
comedy and humor and i just started
doing that in drag and once i took the
veil off and kind of became myself and
started doing my own thing i noticed
that people cared and people paid
attention and that kind of got me to the
next level
wow okay you're have you done drag
before then so i'm actually a
professional makeup artist but it wasn't
my goal to fool them it was more just
like i need to stand still because i
know i cannot walk in these heels but i
look so good so
i was like if i just stand still
nobody's gonna clock this nobody's gonna
know thank you so much for watching we
would love to hear your comments who
looked the most glamorous probably me
i think so
don't forget to like this up and also
subscribe if you enjoyed i'll catch you
on the next one and don't be mad at us
[Music]
you